let's continue taking call 617 830 4750
who's next up today hello hello oh this
is is it the david pakman show it is
you're on the show where we're taking
calls who is this uh my name is Varun um
and like I had a pretty good question if
I could ask by please by all I do you
view the presidential race as a foreman
race like you think the third parties
have pretty good chance of winning no I
think that neither uh Gary Johnson or
jill stein have any chance of winning
whatsoever why why not because I'm
looking at the polls and jill stein
would be lucky to get three or four
percent and Gary Johnson would be very
very lucky to get six or seven percent
so I Justin going off of the polls I
mean well at least getting the debate 50
cent I'm sorry your you cut out a little
bit you're saying who might get fifteen
percent Gary Johnson getting fifteen
percent I don't see it happening I mean
so that would be the threshold in an
average of polls to participate in the
national debates uh I think he was close
to that you know in Utah he's polling
sixteen percent but I I just don't think
he's even going to get on the national
debate stage I think that's just the
reality uh i mean i'm paying actually an
excuse to give up though no i'm not
saying you should give up your question
was do I think he's got a chance of
being the president and my answer is no
but I by all means stay in it and third
parties are important third parties are
important we had another question about
that today uh but but you know your
question was do I think that either any
third party chick and it has a chance to
be the president and I think the answer
is clearly no not this year that makes
sense
alright thank you for the call very good
question i like that question because
it's just very direct do i think the k
any of these third-party candidates have
a shot of being the next president the
night I like being able to Stan sir
answer clearly